hot breath what's goody hot breathaverse
welcome back to Hot Breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros I
am your host comedian Joel Byers and our
episode today is a first of its kind we
have an announcement and I'm bringing on
a previous guest to break the news with
me so please welcome back to the hot
breath of verse hot Brethren and sister
in the one and only
Mr Brandon Lewin everyone I feel like
bro after like off the phone doing the
evangelicus or whatever the Angelicus
yeah yeah you I feel like you're gonna
[__] sell me like on religion right
now I look like a youth pastor you do I
do like I came in here to lay hands on
this whole operation what do we call you
earlier buddy Olsteen buddy
Olsteen's younger brother I'm the good
one all right I'll let you in if there's
a flood I don't keep my money in the
bathroom I I keep it on the counter
all right oh here we go
that's good man that's real good yeah
my wife's ready for me to go viral so
I'm gonna do this until we pop off yeah
you look like you're kind of constipated
though a little bit it's the Holy Spirit
the Holy Spirit moving through that was
the announcement today Joel's
constipated and he's got a new
impression
so that's what we doing today fam yeah
we got excited yeah we got comedy fam in
here Brandon did the podcast a few
months ago now maybe several months ago
it was almost like a year ago was it
almost a year I remember I was in New
York when we did it wow yeah so yeah it
was probably in like July July of last
year that's wild man that explains the
love then it's been growing and
fermenting that's right planted the seed
then we basically did the podcast
together and hit it off really well what
brand is doing with big laugh here in
Austin is incredible and I'll get him to
talk about it a little bit more what
I've been doing here at hot breath for
the past six or seven years is
interviewing over 400 comedians all
about the craft of Comedy to help
educate aspiring and working Comics but
to also give comedy fans that peek
behind the curtain of what it actually
takes to become a comedy Superstar so
Brandon has worked with some of the
biggest comedians in the game as well so
maybe tell them a little bit about big
laugh before we get into what's
happening yeah man you know first I want
to just give you praise because I like I
I loved when I came on the show it was
by far one of my favorite experiences
and I had no idea who the [__] you were
like you you you hit me up I think you
DM me on Instagram you're like hey I got
this podcast I checked it I was like oh
[__] you got some serious guests on here
I'm like all right cool and I was like
we jumped on we talked and like you said
we vibed and that was like the best part
because we aligned with everything but
what you've done and now you've come
here to Austin you're hanging out here
you're walking down the streets you're
going into [__] the mothership and
people are recognizing you they're like
no it's so it's really you and the real
person like people saw you off the
street man I was like it was is wild and
um and it just goes to show like what
you're doing and what hot breath does
for comedians is exactly aligns exactly
with what we're doing to a big laugh
comedy and I just I love to see it
because I think I told you this before
off off the mic but when I first started
doing comedy six years ago I I'm a nerd
so I try to research as much as possible
and there was like nothing out there
that really told you like how to write a
joke I even reached out to I would just
tweet or like DM bigger comedians like
hey what do I do and their advice always
was stage time stage time stay time
stage time and as a comedian never or a
person who's never been up on stage I
was like what the [__] does that mean
like I didn't know what that meant to be
honest with you now I get it I totally
get it and that's what I tell other
people but I try to explain it but like
what you provide as far as helping
people figure out how to joke write
jokes but also pulling the curtain
behind and and showing uh people what
comedians have to go through like the
stories that I'm sure you've you've
heard and and people that share on this
podcast gives other people hope because
it's not that easy it's hard hard
[__] working everyone goes through
their own trials and tribulations to get
to a certain point like Andrew Schultz
didn't start off I mean he had a hard
time breaking into the comedy scene for
a long time but people don't see that
they see him now buying his own comedy
special back from Amazon and then
selling it or selling himself and making
millions and millions of dollars that's
what they see they don't see that
struggle and you showcase and highlight
the struggle and I think that's
extremely important and the stories
behind each comedian are extremely
important too and it's not shared enough
so Bravo to you man thank you man it was
the show that I wish existed so I
created you know and that's amazing and
Bravo too and what you've been able to
do at Big laugh not only giving
comedians a platform to create their own
content their own podcasts and stuff but
also what you guys have done especially
where in the pandemic where it seeming
like there was no hope you guys really
gave hope to a lot of Comedians and a
lot of people that oh it's it's gonna be
all right and there is another way to do
comedy because I've been doing comedy 13
years I can tell you I can't tell you
just the the gatekeeper side of this and
that whole competitive mentality over
like supportive and nurturing mentality
and what you guys have really cultivated
here with big laugh is like an Open Arms
approach for connecting Comedians and
comedy fans and the name game speaks for
itself I mean big laugh you know and you
guys do that both on stage and off stage
with the content you create and there's
just such a
natural organic connection between hot
breath and big laugh yeah there really
is and I appreciate that a lot man and
you know when we first started comedy
it's and big laugh comedy I mean it
really I started doing it solo I had a
self I was producing shows on my own and
did it in like small venues but my
biggest thing from the get-go is
make it into a business friendly show
right a lot of comedians I notice here
in Austin pre-pandemic would do comedy
shows but they do it either for free or
they charge like a small amount of money
so they never would make money off the
show and comedians would be really
talented and they would go up there and
they get paid in drink tickets or
mozzarella sticks and it's like everyone
should get [__] paid something right
like a small amount put some monetary
value even if you get 20 people out but
if those 20 people are paying 20 a
ticket that means that's 400 right there
that could go towards the the the the
rest of the Comedians and split among
them and then you're paying bills and
you're making your dream into a real
life work and and living situation
that's the hard thing right like a lot
of comedians start off they live in the
cars they're getting paid [__] so you
know for from us from the get-go when I
did bar shows I remember I paid this
girl Jacqueline
um I forgot her last name lanona I think
it was but she's base out of here I
don't know if she still does comedy but
she came on a show and I I saw her on a
bunch of flyers and other shows in
Austin and I put her on mine I gave her
like five or ten minutes and I paid her
35 bucks I then mowed her and she's like
she screenshot it and she's like Brandon
she's like this is the first time I ever
got paid for a comedy show I was like
shut the [__] up are you serious I'm
like I see you all over town like this
is the first time she's like yeah I was
like well we're gonna have to do more of
these so that's what we did man and we
still do it to this day and that's what
I love about what we're doing like when
we started off a big Live Comedy
um it's always been about the comedians
it's always always about giving them
opportunity the other thing is like this
the scene
has a lot of bad apples in it not
necessarily comedians but the business
side of it agents can be kind of
cutthroat you have club Owners that
don't treat comedians the proper way I
can't tell you the horror stories I hear
and it makes me sick to my stomach
personally because we I always try to
take care and make Fair deals with
comedians giving them opportunities to
do things and if they take it and they
run with it then they get paid for it
and they get paid for it very handsome
amen and and that's the way it should be
you know and it should be a a good
healthy relationship between the people
who are either producing uh the shows or
the comedy club Owners and the comedians
it but it a lot of times the club Owners
especially the older ones because
they're a little old school and they're
a little jaded but they look at
comedians just like a dollar sign they
get them in they get them out they don't
really treat them right and from for our
our philosophy is that we're taking care
of we have two customers we have the
comedy fans and we have The Comedians
and our goal is always to provide the
best customer service and the best
experience for both sides every single
time whether that's in person or online
and so you know we're all about
comedians we're pro comedians Pro like
and which is funny to say because you
you shouldn't have to say it if you're
like your job a lot side comedians but
you kind of have to though like I think
more comedians will understand that than
like the regular fan because the fan
doesn't see all the [__] that
happens behind there but I mean I was
telling Corey some Horror Story about
um a comedian that we all know that uh
he was featuring in a club and um he got
a call about headlining another gig that
was gonna pay him like three times the
amount of money and so he found a
replacement to feature who was a very
good replacement the club owner told him
is if you ever [__] if he ever if he
didn't play his Club he would never play
there [__] again wow and and it's I
hear that type of [__] I'm like man this
is stupid it so it takes both sides to
really work right like you know the
comedian teens need the clump owners and
they need the producers and vice versa
you know and and then everyone needs the
the customers so anyway uh I got a
little down the that rabbit hole no I
mean you're passionate about it and I
mean as a as a professional comedian
myself that's what really stood out is
just the difference and and your vision
and your approach to Comedy and the
business you I mean you came from a
successful like marketing background
with like big companies so me also
seeing Oh okay there the comedy business
is outdated it's a little stale it is
and it's primed for disruption yep and I
see what you're doing a big laugh is
like right the tip of the Spear of that
disruption and I I want I wanted to be
in on it yep and that so that's that's
the announcement yeah style people
that's the announcement so big uh big
laugh is proud to announce that we're
bringing over hot breath to the network
let's go let's go
[Laughter]
um what's goody Hopper at the verse if
you're loving this episode and all the
other awesome content you get here for
free then you are going to love our
brand new hot breath VIP list all you
got to do to join is go to
hotbreathpodcast.com VIP and you're
gonna get exclusive access to not just
podcasts but also other content like
unseen interviews merch drops discounts
giveaways and a lot more exciting things
and this is for everyone if you're an
aspiring or working comedian or just a
comedy fan that loves getting those
behind the scenes nuggets You're Gonna
Love what we have here at the new hot
breath VIP list so go to the link in the
description or join at hot
breathpodcast.com VIP and I'll see you
there speaking of Comedy I've gotta
shout out the network behind this show
big laugh comedy they have been killing
it in the Texas comedy scene producing
some of the big biggest shows live and
also podcasts like the one you're
watching here and even bigger news big
laugh is hitting the road bringing their
best comedians and shows to a city like
yours so do yourself a favor join their
VIP newsletter and get exclusive access
to not just when they're coming to your
city but also even more fun content and
even comedy news so all you got to do is
go to blcomedy.com VIP HB or hit the
link in the description we'll see you
there yeah it's really exciting it's
been a long time coming we've been
working on it for a while but now it's
finally here you came into Austin we
filmed a bunch of podcasts great guests
got you on a few so excited for the
future man I mean I I don't know if you
want to share but I'll I'll share a
little bit about what we've been talking
about it's just taking hot breath and
doing more of what you're doing but
really also expanding to understand that
like I think the show was kind of
branded in the sense of just for
Comedians and people were aspiring to be
comedians but I truly believe that this
show is more than just that it is that
but it's also about the comedy nerds
people just want to hear a good story
about someone because comedians are
truly entrepreneurs right and and they
struggle they go through that ups and
downs they deal with all sorts of [__]
and it's the same thing but like sharing
their stories is important for other
people to hear so they know that they're
not alone and that there's other
opportunities for for them whether it's
in comedy or not really that's what it
comes down to so that's what we're doing
hot breath we're expanding the [__]
hot breath universe and then uh putting
you in a real studio and in hotlanta
yeah yeah and uh we're gonna [__]
blow this [__] up man no I'm excited oh
my gosh it just makes my heart smile to
just um
your best your best so far was yesterday
when you sat there and you're like this
is surreal like I don't have to do
anything
I just been bootstrapping dude I mean
I've I've flown and you've done a great
job though man yeah I appreciate that
dude I mean the the early days were
literally like I'd fly to La for
interviews I mean I accidentally deleted
an episode with a comedian in Atlanta so
then I flew to LA to get that interview
uh again and just uh cards disrupting or
like malfunction I mean I've been
there's there's a a very big comedian I
was supposed to interview in my recorder
didn't work and we literally said I'm
not kid because he he was a fan of the
podcast and he was excited to do it I
don't want it I don't want to drop the
name but it's it's it's yeah and um he
was like dude he's like listen we're
friends now and um and I told him I was
like I mean you know well I'm gonna be
having this I don't this hadn't happened
yet and I was like well I'm about to get
a studio set up so I was like we'll just
save it for then he's like let's save it
let's do it the right way because this
was in his green room after a show not a
green room it was in the dressing room
oh wow but and um he's like let's do it
the right way he's like when he's like
when you get your studio he's like you
have my word we're gonna do it that's
awesome and we like had a heart to heart
there and then so this to be happening
now you know for doing it just a one-man
band for so long man it's just it's it's
such a relief to be around other
like-minded people and to really it's
fun man uh change the comedy business in
the in a positive way yeah well to do
anything great you have to have a team
behind you right yeah like the big
comedians they all have a team behind
them Jen who's just on the podcast so
I'm sure we'll see this you'll see the
episode after this one yeah but she has
a team now you know and and everyone
talks about it it's like that's the next
progression and and it's like that in
all businesses right like if you're
running a solo business eventually if
you want to grow you cannot do
everything yourself you have to get to
the next level and bring on people to
help you and look at you man you got you
got a team behind you now let's go baby
let's go hot breath fam this is
beautiful dude
so A lot's going to be changing in a
very positive direction yep
um you know I've been consistent posting
the podcast but there's gonna be so much
more now that we're going to be doing
with the the YouTube channel the content
creation side of it in terms of just
social media in general and the the
newsletter
the hot breath VIP newsletter that I'm
so excited about and make sure you guys
go sign up yeah go right now go to the
website hit the link down in the
description make sure you sign up for
that VIP because there's gonna be a lot
of great exclusive content you won't be
able to get anywhere else so make sure
you go do that right now yeah because
hot breath is first and foremost a
community you know and uh the the big
laugh culture and I think the hot breath
culture really worked together well and
really I feel like we can really um take
the community to that next level and
make an even more connected and intimate
with that newsletter the hot breath VIP
so 100
just makes a heart and I know my wife is
so happy as well
well I I just want to like kind of touch
a little bit more on what you were
saying is like yeah for everybody is
like the the content is gonna be a lot
more of the same but also we're gonna
dig deeper into some of the topics and
um just you know just [__] blow this
stuff up man I mean the the ideas that
we have been brainstorming talking since
you've been down here is just tremendous
and and so you know a lot of it is gonna
be like we're gonna be providing more uh
interviews but exclusive content then
we're gonna have some
um some fun giveaways creating some
merch throwing that out there I mean I
know you guys already have merch but a
little bit more of it and
um even some live shows man we're gonna
we're gonna get hot breath out there and
in front of a live audience and do some
and bring some big names on there too to
help but also help spread the culture
and and share you know more information
for comedians to help them become
bigger and hit their goals faster too
yeah dude yeah I mean I flew in
yesterday got in at noon started
recording at two and we've basically
just been creating content ever since
that's right I love the plan so you are
a Workhorse my friend I appreciate that
yeah man we ain't aiming for the middle
here now no no this is gonna be speaking
of not aiming for the middle can I can I
make a quick little announcement myself
besides this one please which feeds into
because we're gonna do well the first
live hot breath we're gonna do from the
first big laugh comedy club which is
opened up in Fort Worth Texas very soon
we're super excited about that it's
gonna be uh just a lot of the same of
what we've been doing but now we have uh
our own place to do it our own home we
have full control over what we're going
to be doing there and we're going to
bring in you know everyone from big name
comedians to you know smaller name
comedians helping people develop we're
going to have actually multiple rooms in
there so we're gonna have two rooms
One's Gonna Be smaller about 100 people
we're gonna have a bigger room this
could be about 300 people and then it's
gonna be set up to do some wild stuff
and we'll be able to not just do live
shows but also create content and create
art and put out specials and all sorts
of stuff so our goal is to make it the
best comedy club in in the world and in
the states and well the world let's just
say the world yeah because I don't know
how how well the comedy clubs are over
overseas yet but this is first of many
for us and we're super excited and we're
gonna bring Joel out there and do some
stuff and then we're also gonna be you
know really catering a lot to the the
local scene but also helping us in scene
2 since we got our Roots down here
bringing in comedians up there expanding
their their uh brand and helping them
grow as well so this is this is fun
stuff man I'm I'm super excited it's
been a lot of time coming though too
it's like fun oh yeah it's been uh it's
been like two years in the works but you
know it you know good things come to
those who wait yes I guess so we were
just waiting you know you guys just you
know produce the Matt Rife special so it
was only right that now we're like all
right all right hot breath hot breath's
gonna come in there
we tipped her we dipped our toes in the
water a little bit now we can make a big
splash
exactly so this is going to be a
beautiful thing so yes don't forget join
that hot breath VIP newsletter subscribe
to the YouTube channel and really leave
your comments on this video about what
you're most excited about in the future
of the comedy industry and what you're
most excited about with this new
partnership and really almost like
family I would say I mean it's it's it's
it's it's real I've been in the game
long enough to know and
feel the difference between when
something is a maybe and when something
is a home run and I've haven't felt more
confident about any project that I've
attached myself to or hot bread there's
a reason hot breath has been solo for so
long because I've been waiting for the
right opportunity and other offers have
been out there but this was worth the
wait and it's gonna be awesome game
changer yeah so who do I write that
check out to yeah well Joel Byers LLC
we'll keep it we'll keep it off the hot
breath books I'll give you my wife's
venmo we'll keep it on that you never
saw this
it's gonna be great well thank you man I
appreciate it I'm super excited about
this too let's get this party rocking
man comedy history that's right it's a
wrap High breath